en este vídeo haremos una introducción
rápida a los carbohidratos tal vez ya
estén familiarizados con el concepto
cuando observan un empaque de comida
generalmente se encuentran con una
etiqueta nutricional que dice
carbohidratos y ahí nos dicen los gramos
de carbohidratos que contiene ese
alimento por porción
no todos los carbohidratos son
comestibles pero algunos sí y muchos de
los alimentos que consumimos contienen
algún carbohidrato pero que son
realmente bueno si analizamos la palabra
podemos ver que inicia con carbón así
que tiene algo que ver con los carbonos
y después dice hidratos que tiene algo
que ver con agua si dijeron eso están
muy cerca porque los carbohidratos
involucran carbonos de hecho aquí
tenemos un carbohidrato simple muy común
la molécula de glucosa y representados
de color gris oscuro podemos ver que
tiene 6 carbonos mientras que la parte
hidrato se refiere a que los
carbohidratos generalmente contienen
oxígeno e hidrógeno
proporción como ocurre en el agua es
decir que por cada oxígeno
tenemos dos hidrógenos y eso lo podemos
ver aquí porque en la glucosa tenemos 1
2 3 4 5 6 oxígenos y 12 hidrógenos de
ahí proviene esta palabra ahora otra
palabra que generalmente se utiliza en
lugar de carbohidratos es el término
sacar ido sacar ido proviene del griego
y se refiere a algo dulce como el azúcar
eso tiene sentido porque si probamos la
glucosa se darán cuenta de que sabe
dulce algo muy interesante sobre esto es
que la glucosa puede ser una molécula
única es decir un azúcar simple o puede
formar moléculas grandes en donde la
glucosa actúa como bloques de
construcción por ejemplo aquí tenemos
una parte de la molécula de glucógeno y
como podemos ver simplemente es una
secuencia repetida de moléculas de
glucosa entonces algo como esto se le
conoce como monosacárido
es un azúcar simple y al glucógeno se le
conoce como polisacárido polisacárido
otra forma de verlo es que la glucosa es
el bloque de construcción del glucógeno
otros términos que tal vez se encuentren
son monómero y polímero por ejemplo si
construimos una molécula muy grande a
partir de una cadena de moléculas
pequeñas los bloques de construcción se
consideran monómeros y la molécula que
construimos con esos monómeros es
nuestro polímero y como veremos más
adelante
el fenómeno monómero polímero no está
limitado únicamente para los
carbohidratos osácar y 2 sino que
también encontraremos esa relación en
otras cosas como los aminoácidos y las
proteínas pero qué papel juegan los
carbohidratos en los sistemas biológicos
bueno los carbohidratos o zachary 2
generalmente se asocian con la fuente de
energía la glucosa se puede convertir
rápidamente en energía en
células biológicas y el glucógeno es un
almacén de energía en el hígado y los
músculos que se pueden separar en
moléculas de glucosa que son una fuente
de energía disponible fácilmente ahora
en las plantas
algunos de estos polisacáridos pueden
jugar un papel de estructura y aquí
podemos hablar de cosas como la celulosa
que también es un polisacárido entonces
pueden jugar un papel estructural
vamos a dejarlo hasta aquí ya nos
concentramos en un tipo de monosacárido
que fue la glucosa y un tipo de
polisacáridos como el glucógeno más
adelante veremos que la glucosa aparece
mucho pero también existen otros tipos
de monosacáridos y de polisacáridos en
particular los polisacáridos forman
parte de un grupo más amplio de
moléculas conocidas como macromoléculas
y como podemos imaginar el prefijo macro
hace referencia a moléculas grandes que
generalmente contienen miles de átomos
pero no se confunden las macromoléculas
son muy grandes pero siguen siendo parte
del nivel atómico cada una de estas
esferas sigue siendo un átomo así que
todavía necesitamos un microscopio muy
muy poderoso para poder observar algunas
de las macromoléculas más grandes
incluyendo a los polisacáridos nos vemos
en los siguientes vídeos